hello guys and welcome to another video
so we have some news regarding the
Mandalorian season 3 and this is some
disappointing news as we have the
runtime for the first episode now this
comes from reliable sources as they have
been cracked on previous run times for
episode so they say the first episode of
Roman law in season three goes for 35
minutes and 16 seconds I also believe
this includes the end credits as well
now this is kind of no surprise as the
previous man Lauren episodes do average
around this time with an exception of a
through longer episodes but I gotta say
this is quite disappointing after we've
got shows like and or which generally
had longer form episodes and now I'm
just been watching The Last of Us which
consistently has longer episodes and I
really really enjoy the format of having
this you know longer amount of time to
spend with the characters you get that
more character development to get to
spend more time with them and you
frankly get more attached to the
characters in the story now I will say
the runtime doesn't dictate how good an
episode is you know just think back to
the Clone Wars all those are very very
short episodes but yet there's such
great episodes so I'm sure evil way is
going to be a fantastic episode but I
just like the longer episodes where we
get to spend more time with the
characters and stuff but what do you
guys thought let me know in the comments
section below do you guys prefer longer
form episodes are you okay with getting
some short episodes and if you haven't
already please do consider subscribing
thanks for watching guys